d'abord il ya eu la prof et ses
chroniques puis je lui ai inventé des
personnages
aliénor lucrecia et tous les autres de
passage sont trop réfléchir à leur
histoire
et enfin enfin 2017 j'ai eu l'idée d'une
un scénario qui expliquerait la présence
de ces personnages dans notre époque
avec de l'humour de l'action et des
histoires de voyage dans le temps je me
suis amusé à l'écrire mais je me suis
ensuite retrouvé avec un script dont je
ne savais pas trop quoi faire je n'avais
jamais réalisé autre chose que mes
chroniques seul devant ma bibliothèque
est à moi qui me paraissait bien trop
ambitieux là l'équipe entre en jeu les
gens d'aller dans
savoir s'entourer c'est super important
tous ces gens ont boosté mon envie de
mener ce projet à bien vous encourager à
passer des heures sur des plans de
travail et des découpages technique
parce que je me disais que ça en
vaudrait la peine
il a rapidement eu loup qui j'ai proposé
de coréaliser la série et puis les potes
vidéaste qui ont rejoint la troupe côté
technique ou côté acteurs apparente
onnaing qu'on nous a chaudement
recommandé aux sons
toute l'équipe était constituée d'amis
que je connaissais déjà et c'est plutôt
pratique
[Musique]
les premiers jours de tournage
après plusieurs mois de préparatifs et
un chrono tuning réussies ont eu lieu
chez moi dans le nord il fait des
contraintes de chacun on ne pouvait
tourner que le week-end c'est là qu'on a
tourné toutes les séquences dans
l'appartement de la prof puisque c'est
le mien logiquement ce qui a occasionné
un sacré bordel dans mon salon mais je
peux dire que nous étions très efficace
c'est pas venu pour vous de faire
classer au patrimoine de l'unesco tous
les châteaux ayant appartenu à des rois
de france et déclare à ce sujet tueur
quelqu'un est un disque 800 artistes
rice
[Musique]
la gueuse je trouve afin qu'elle puisse
réfléchir à la fête sans toucher à la
paix mais on a fait des choix importants
c'est marrant parce que positionner plus
maman après accord
en phase iv d'ensemble a légèrement
meilleures ici précisément non neige
s'est abattue près du tout en tête du
classement désolé je recommande à
présent je fais comme ça lafarge est
attendu c'est pourquoi on est ici
précisé mon nom mais c'est moi une autre
fois c'est promis
ces deux éléments fondamentaux mâchoire
les activités ingénierie magnifiques
costumes et gbowee j'ai beaucoup aimé le
travail sur les personnages
l'ambiance la réalisation vraiment cinq
sur cinq et puis les effets spéciaux
épaules alors franchement ils sont de
toute beauté
[Musique]
ce week-end là on a aussi tourné les
scènes du café malgré un imprévu de
taille permet aujourd'hui soirée ou
demain samedi à partir de 14 heures que
je quitte alors et dimanche et réouvrir
aliments 10 juin à 9h bombe a devancé
van hover pour 9 heures ma fille tu peux
rester jusqu'à quand au pire la pression
à mes biens c'est dommage
rafik
du coup on a dû y retourner le lendemain
et faire du doublage parce que même un
dimanche à 11 heures du mat et il ya du
monde dans un petit café de village et
puis les scènes en forêt pour time warp
j'ai pris trois tic alors on est content
oui enfin de parler à un moment il faut
qu'ils arrivent dans tout ça vous allez
faire un très bon parce que je sais
exactement où je suis je peux faire la
viola
là tu dis quoi tu dis moi je fais on
fait la page 3 tu me traites à la pique
on va perdre tout le dialogue 3g star
will have to dial up contre tout le
dialogue ici dit mademoiselle ali n'en
ont pas ok d'accord il fait ce que
j'avais beaucoup rouge entraîne comme tu
veux absolument courir pour nous c'est
le chant que tu voies dont il doit soit
partir encore en ce qu il faut qu on
m'appelle je ne sais pas mais le faucon
millenium hockey non je ne vote je ne te
vois pas moi qui ne veut toujours pas ça
commence si voilà c'est bon pour notre
image annonce épisode 1 53 plants cinq
prises une
personne ne marche pas je lance
[Rires]
j'entraîne les faucons les faucons
minutes ok les impacts et les se mesure
en watts en face des coups à jouer ce
sont 17 la tête en tête impose
j'entraîne les faucons du duc et ils
veulent en ce moment c'est l'exercice 7
buts de l'exercice vol à voile en ce
moment c'est le but de l'exercice
mais que vaut votre présence en ces
lieux c'est la saison soit je ne vous
dérangerait pas plus longtemps mais dans
les fermes et bien d'autres câbles n'ai
pas de fonction
ce premier week-end de tournage a eu
lieu en juin 2018 en août deux autres
week-end était prévue à paris pour le
reste l'équipe étant largement
parisienne c'était plus pratique et
rentable que ce soit moi qui me déplace
si les choses
quand et leurs affidés monstre sur la
plage
c'est moi est ce que tu dirais
m
c'est patent pool il dit
c'est ma soeur paule en fait acheté le
suppose alors quand une idée mon stock
du tout on appelle ce n'est de se pose
ac je suppose d'en bas quant à leurs
affidés millions ce truc dont l'appel à
la cour
merci à nos drapeaux dormir je n'ai pas
mis en doute et consommait pas sur toi
vivement les vacances
oh pas sauvé
vous savez
donc là le jeu
le
cela à l'image
pense pas que je passe
plus faire un effort sur la tenue quand
même bon se retourne pour regarder à
part ça c'est moi qui suffisait si tu
penses que je vais revêtir ses vêtements
ridicule qui pour le pilote dans le
rectum détonne passion jet et laisse moi
parler pour pierce et rapidité et ma
soeur paule
on a pu tourner au tennessee jazz bar où
bosse et guillaume notre agent thierry
est barman à ses heures le bar était
très beau et plus calmes que le petit
pmu de mon village puisqu'on l'avait
rien que pour nous elle est on va
voilà ce dernier savait pas une panne
tous opérateurs nous a dit qu'elle se
trouvait ici ma soeur fois oui assez et
on va des flux que quand elle aura fini
de nous sommes pour la merci avec très
peu dormi en france mais pas sur tout
mais qu'on se met pas sur tout
pour trois plans un prix ce 4
c'est bien ça ici je sois pas là je veux
faire je peux faire mieux faire
ce qu'il veut
bref on va faire
j'ai donné pitié
[Musique]
non justin tu arrêtes bonjour comité
devant échanges et rooney ont 120
anneaux quelle était la butte
enfin france 2
d'accord
yes
ils repèrent s'il vous plaît je vais pas
sur le making of est ce que vous pouvez
leur faire journée le lendemain
changement de lieu grâce à notre ami
pierre karner on avait accès à
l'université paris diderot pour toutes
les scènes du futur ok une fac c'est
parce qu'il ya de plus futuriste mais je
voulais justement quelque chose de
neutre et cyber historiens reçoivent des
gens de toutes les époques chez eux
alors il est normal qu'il ne veut pas
montrer trop de détails de leur époque
pour ça les couloirs de l'université
était parfait permettait des travellings
de qualité de six séquences quatre plans
quatre prises 2 mai godefroy qu'est ce
que vous faites ici je rentrais de la
forêt où je vous ai croisé et femmes
très étranger venu m'aborder pour me
demander de venir lui parler de ma vie
dont le futur vous rendez compte
oui puisqu'on avait aussi la famille
mais ça vous prend souvent suivre
démarrant au milieu des bois
elle m'a assuré que ce n'était pas de la
sorcellerie et puis elle nous ressemble
c'est bien ce que je pensais vous n'êtes
pas mais non mais comment ça elle veut
ressembler il y avait un vrai air de
famille mais à part les cheveux et
l'habillement
mais c'est pas possible qu'on n'est pas
par an on peut pas avoir la même
descendance
[Musique]
non évidemment un prix juste à tête
sinon lucrecia champions fiancé lui
aussi un ancien policier hop et le gros
soupir le programme était de plus en
plus serrés ce jour là on avait 38 ans a
tourné en une dizaine d'heures ce qui
signifie beaucoup de stress et de
fatigue
épisode 6 et comme cette lan 8 prises
une justement c'est ça qu'on doit parler
on y va son meilleur rôle genton
deuxième nommé godefroy qui n'a pas
donné suite
ces gens de faire des réglages mais
votent pour ça aussi en avec ma fille
nous ça veut dire qu'il est noir reste
ici et moi
par contre plus de 8 ouais et attrapes
moins bien joué et c'est qu'on voit là
précédemment attrape-moi le poignet
comme ça attention gauche ici bas
le dernier jour florence notre astre et
de slash cyber historienne nous prêter
son quartier dans une ruelle proche de
chez elle on a pu tourner les scènes
d'aliénor vieux de 3 ces contrôles
entreprise qu est ce que je suis parti
en train d'avancer je dois repartir sur
le plan d'urgence commence de la route
aux j'avance un peu filer et raffi par
contre c'est d'ailleurs la série n'est
pas vraiment situer dans l'espace
puisque on a tourné à la fois dans le
nord et à paris située dans le temps me
semblait plus important
excusez moi
voilà
on est de mieux en mieux donc en
attendant ces pirates je sais pas vous
mais non mais moi je du coup j'étais en
train de faire les deux je pense qu'elle
est dans un bar je pense florence nous a
aussi prêté sa cave pour quelques
torture et autres joyeusetés
guillaume a un peu souffert pour de vrai
à cause de ses biens elle dit que j'ai
dit que je me concentrais lis tu te dis
tu le dit il on te tapes pour de vrai
concentré de gamme de styles jusqu'à ce
que tu ressors par les paliers nord est
a déjà commencé on fait quoi alors je
mets le voir de fer rougi dans les mains
si nous avions rendez-vous pour éduquer
au niveau risque de voilà qui peut rien
d'accord alors j'attends vos idées si on
avait commencé par soumettre l'agent
david on n'a pas filer c'est encore moi
yes est un coupé aliénor fini à l'énorme
horse à liège paris nord c'est bon ok
pendant ce temps là vous faites est ma
clé la ba vi là encore il y avait plus
de trente plomb a tourné sur la journée
interrompue chaque fois que quelqu'un
entrer dans la cave
autant dire que le stress est monté mais
qu'on a su être efficaces et bouclé dans
les temps avec une scène finale
magnifique de réalisme mais c'est quoi
ce bordel c'est bête mais je crois qu'on
en sait plus du tout chez lui il a dû
partir en vacances
le croit parce qu'on a paru métamorphosé
loin d'être finie il avait fallu
plusieurs mois pour monter le projet
deux mois au total pour le tourner et un
an pour monter et effectué toute la post
prod des épisodes blot s'est chargée du
montage et des effets spéciaux dave du
mixage son et j'ai été particulièrement
impressionné par le travail de valentin
notre compositeur
si vous ne l'aviez pas fait je vous
conseille de prêter attention aux
musiques de la série parce que je trouve
magnifique comme son travail en général
en fait
[Musique]
je suis valentin ancien et je suis
compositeur sur la série terra donc pour
travailler sur la série enfin yeux donc
je reçois le l'image qui est monté par
par amour et injuste il est ensuite je
analyse un petit peu le l'épisode 2 en
essayant de poser la question de roue on
en a besoin de musique
et puisque la musique pourrait raconter
en fait
et à partir de là je commence à faire un
tour de brouillon enfin pose des idées
en fait au piano porte directement dans
le logiciel
ce que j'ai un levier permet à la fin
d'abord l'image et à la fin d'avoir des
marqueurs sur lequel me servir de repère
dans l'épisode et à partir de ça je fais
un brouillon et ensuite à partir de ce
moment là je veux vraiment réfléchi
complète du siècle instruments en fait
un petit peu l'un sur l'autre
alors en fait le piège du coup c'est son
label à un clavier maître c'est à dire
que c'est un clavier à partir duquel le
jeu contrôler les instruments virtuels
donc qui sont pilotés par ordinateur
fait du world le clavier est relié à
l'ordinateur et par ce biais là il me
suffit de signer en instruments et
virtua qui souvent dans le logiciel au
clavier et en jouant clairet du coup
l'instrument leurs produits par
l'ordinateur et a besoin à ça se trouve
plusieurs co contrôle à ce qu'on appelle
deux contrôleurs midi envoyer leurs
abdos j'utilise principalement c'est
celui ci tient un contrôleur de souffle
c'est incohérent le souffle dedans ça va
contrôler l'intensité du son ont par
exemple si c'est si une flûte ici juste
ou plus ou moins fort on entendra le son
sera plus ou mois comme quand on se
souvient de notre afrique ou dans
n'importe quel instrument à vent
d'ailleurs tu peux aussi l'utiliser pour
d'autres instruments même pas forcément
d'instruments à vent ce qui est très
pratique parce que ça m'évite d'avoir à
contrôler ça avec un autre bouton bien à
devoir ré enregistrer une deuxième passe
en fait justement sur la même main sur
le même extrait sur le clip que j'ai
enregistrée est aussi utilisé ce manque
il pas intérêt mines numérique
bin c'est un instrument électronique à
la basse qu'il est censé être un as
logique mais celui-ci est née mary fils
qui le permet d'être relié à
l'ordinateur et la même façon je peux
contrôler certains paramètres que je
choisis avec lui la position de la main
par rapport à l'antenne fait donc plus
je suis loin je suis proche enfin la
distance à l'antenne 20 on va contrôler
un paramètre de l'instrument en
l'occurrence utilise souvent le parent
avec vibrato c'est là que si si je suis
plus proche de mon psy à moins proche de
mon corps il y aura pas le vibrato du
tout si ma main est très proche de de
l'instrument de l'antenne il réussit
parce que faire un petit élan 69 m
donc là par exemple si je si je joue
avec un violoncelle
je vais contrôler l'intensité du son
avec les souffles et les vibratos 18 en
selle avec la main par rapport à
l'antenne avec des réunions
[Musique]
oh
e
et voilà plus de deux ans après que le
projet ait débuté des derniers éléments
se mettent en place
ce fut une expérience folle stressante
enrichissante et que je voudrais
évidemment continuer avec la saison 2
elle est déjà écrite mais la pré
production n'a pas encore commencé en
attendant de la part de toute l'équipe
merci à toutes les personnes qui ont
contribué à encourager ou regarder time
warp
[Musique]